traitor caught in the act in these
grainy images David Smith a security
guard at the British Embassy in Berlin
is filming sensitive CCTV footage to
send to his Russian pay masters little
did he know he was facing an elaborate
trap set for him by MI5
he walked right in and now will spend 13
years behind bars it was your job to
ensure that the embassy was Secure and
its staff safe
you had access to restricted areas of
the building at times when nobody else
was likely to be there
when you did what you did it was the
most obvious breach of the trust placed
in you
over several years Smith passed
sensitive information from the embassy
personal details of Staff a classified
letter intended for the then prime
minister Boris Johnson all to his
Russian contacts you were fully aware
that you should not have copied any of
these documents
and were equally aware that were these
documents to get into the wrong hands
they might harm British interests or
pose a threat to the safety of people
working at the embassy the picture that
emerged in court was less the kind of
slick ruthless character you'd expect in
the pages of a John le carre novel and
more a man who was lonely who'd suffered
from mental health issues a drinking
problem and who developed a growing
attachment to conspiracy theories and
fixation with the Russian State when
police raided Smith's Berlin flat they
find a Russian flag a Soviet officer's
hat and other items Clues as to where
his loyalties lay David Smith was
motivated by a combination of two things
greed and a hatred of our country
that hatred
was palpable
and led him into engaging in what can
only be described as really despicable
Behavior
for his crimes Smith seen here wearing
pro-russian emblems will soon dress in a
different color
prison Gray
Matthew Thompson Sky News